hello everybody and welcome to let's
play limbo now this is a game that
people have been asking me to play for a
long time now so I'm actually kind of
glad that I'm getting into it it was 250
on the steam summer sale so if you get a
chance go ahead and pick it up well I
don't know if it's a great game yet but
from what I've heard I've never seen the
game being played or I mean I've seen
screenshots and small clips but I've
never seen any actual of the story but
from what I've heard it's an amazing
game so ah open your eyes uh-huh oh so
it's right into it oh crap man I got to
make sure the volume is okay
what what what alright okay alright
whatever I'm recording is the audio and
video separately so I'll jot it down if
it needs to be hello ah yeah you team it
yay OOP nope uh-huh alright Boing Boing
Boing Boing
when I was in art school for a semester
a lot of people did art based on the
style of limbo and this is actually
really cool I really like it hello what
just done hello
ah Wow
okay now what are the controls oh okay
well that's simple oh yeah bleep fall
down ah ah those who are spikes dang it
ah alright well you all are very
confirming that this is a markiplier
let's play because I died on quite
possibly the easiest thing alright
ignoring that that never happened
I know I know
pushing something control ah pulling
something all it come on you wimp huh
yeah ah I can climb hey grab it let go
of it Oh climb down I guess that's okay
too
into the depths why not now let's see
what we got here
interesting very physics based I'm
picking up probably another pit of doom
here oh boo yeah is that a pit of doom I
want to find out up up that up can't
swim apparently okay this is coming
okay up up okay and then down not
falling in the pit of doom this time
because that's stupid and I won't do it
anymore all right
Badou oh yeah oh yeah I'm the best oh
yeah I can jump across a chasm boat yeah
go go yeah grab a mast go grab it
what are you doing I guess I have no
control over where think about goes huh
yeah yeah yeah
I'll wait I do have control no I don't
that was a lie and apparently I can't
swim so I won't be jumping in the water
anytime soon but there DARPA ticket duck
boom yeah yeah alright so right Wow
smash my face right into the hillside
what the hell maybe pull AHA very
physics-based you like it squish oh yeah
parkour parkour how's this kid get here
anyway
this is a kid right oh yeah leap parkour
yeah I would have trusted that yeah
parkour wait till I can do 360s pet leak
moves point
something's gonna happen
ooh what's that
ah he's look dangerous
I should probably not jumps face-first
into them but whenever I ever listen to
good reason swap that's grody gruesome
yep
haha epic hello little fireflies not
here to kill me are you
Oh what the hell is that better jump on
it up wait wait what it's not what I
think maybe if I pull it down it'll snap
on that thing ha ha
nope ah was a bad idea putting that
there
what I keep falling off cuz I suck
there we go maybe I could have gotten
that but oh yeah that is what I'm
supposed to do it's gonna pull it a
little more to them laughs yeah get up
there kid but to who walk ya up yeah
soli parkour can I get up there huh
I don't know what that was like
something it was a dead body of
something obviously but can't really see
and all this shaded darkness
okay view this is getting kind of creepy
the atmosphere is very very dark grain
gritty and obviously they don't shy away
from death ha ha ha oh yeah Matt damn it
there's no Iowa I would have known with
nothing no way I wouldn't know
oh no Rach no biggie
don't tell me there's another Rock ha ha
ha
anybody else anybody else wanna mess
with me didn't think so
hello Boeing can I get up there
what's it son oh it's water we to push
push I boost you as my buddies from AJ
gaming would say I pushed you
haha nah oh not no water come on kid
it's just a little Bob fine whatever kid
alrighty then I I fish you I pushed you
right in the frigate frak the key is to
breathe out immediately when your head
goes underwater and then breathe in as
hard as you can to fill your lungs with
water water is oxygenated did you know
that you could breathe it come on now
okay bro okay don't jump apparently I
just gotta flip it over and over again
to like it's where I need to go right oh
that's wrong right what down maybe if I
Oh baby I pull the Box over and climb up
on that vine over there using my brain
using my brain I was wondering what it
was a vine dangling here it's probably
wrong - who knows - who - Boosh yeah
yeah boom yeah come on oh don't tell me
that would be nothing there's nothing
there is it there's a whole lot of
nothing
yeah yeah Boop
all right fine well what do i do then
wait no wait wait wait wait wait wait
can I swing or do I just automatically
jump off when I hit left or right that
is the question
huh whoo whoosh AHA aah
I'm the best ish yeah yeah I'm so great
at great game whoosh PACU epic
awesomeness Oh push it all broken arms
I'm just flying through this game I'm
the best
I'll get me up there something else up
there too oh yeah oh yeah whoops oh [ __ ]
I broke it I broke me hopefully save
that I got them aah
I know I know I know I had to swing the
vine
I know back up the Hootie ha fada Daily
News
yeah yes the noises are necessary don't
you know you go farther if you make
noises ha all right yeah I got that
and I'll beat those nice Wang and I
swung and then I swung then I swang a
little bit and then I just
yeah what's this squish altitude is
attitude damn straight
oh yeah not climb back all saving oh
I'll save ya no drop drop
those little kids nimble ha ha oh I made
it anyway okay don't need that box no
more
go log ride this log get it yeah push I
boost you I pushed you I wasn't gonna
make it
I made it yeah who's the man I am hey
with bland what boy I'm a man is that
gonna fall on my head
are those traps up there anyway what is
this place ah oh no whoa
wowie Zowie
what up ah ah ah can't get me oh hello
there hi hi hey what's he doing huh oh
you miss me dick yeah I got you oh I'm
so great okay somehow I gotta get this
down from there maybe oh maybe when he
hit the ground it kind of shook things
what's that oh you can't hit [ __ ]
you ain't got nothing
oh what's that miss oh that sounded like
a duty dude give me that ha ha
on the other side of this and don't fail
don't fail oh I never fail never I'm an
unfailing hey buddy choke on this oh
what's that what's that what's that you
wanna stop me right on yeah dick Oh
[Music]
what's that oh you wanna try again
go target oh yeah I love this so what
[Music]
what I know stupid I just keep it okay
anyway I'm actually running out of time
here so I'll conquer this spider thingy
in the next episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope
you're enjoying this I'm actually having
a lot of fun this is it's actually quite
interesting it's definitely different
mechanics of a game and I always like it
when games try something new and
innovative so expect more this
appreciate I'm gonna go and do a full
playthrough this in the next few days
but obviously tomorrow my 24 hour
livestream and if you're watching from
the future I did a 24 hour charity
livestream it was amazing I was totally
successful and got my goal and
everything yeah totally so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye